a journalism advocacy group says it is
concerned about the Justice Department's
decision to cease phone and email
records of a New York Times reporter the
revelation comes as the federal
government charges the former director
for security of the Senate Intelligence
Committee with leaking information and
then lying about it to the FBI dr. Gaius
has the latest James Wolfe appeared in a
federal courtroom on Friday to face
charges that he lied to the FBI for
months Wolfe had been seen walking the
halls of Congress escorting some of the
most prominent witnesses in the Russia
probe before his Senate investigators as
the Senate intelligence committees
director of security he had access to
classified information some of which
investigators say he was leaking to
reporters including former BuzzFeed
reporter Ali Watkins according to court
documents Wolfe and Watkins had a
four-year relationship prosecutors say
they exchanged tens of thousands of
electronic communications including
daily texts and phone calls they would
also meet in stairwells restaurants and
the reporters apartment investigators
allege Wolfe leaked information about
subpoenas and people under scrutiny by
the Senate Intelligence Committee in
this article on April 3rd 2017 Watkins
wrote about former Trump campaign
foreign policy adviser Carter page who
had agreed to cooperate with the Senate
investigation in December of 2017 FBI
agents interviewed Wolfe about his
contacts with Watkins investigators say
he lied to them
according to the indictment when he was
asked in an FBI questionnaire whether
he'd had a personal relationship with a
reporter he replied no but the FBI
already had pictures of Wolfe
and Watkins together Watkins now works
for the New York Times the newspaper is
reporting that investigators secretly
seized years worth of information
related to who she called and emailed
Watkins denies that Wolfe gave her
classified information and her attorney
says the seizure of her data was
disconcerting for CBS this morning
Saturday Jeff McGee's Washington